if you make 5 divided by 12 and you
press equals right
some of you will get back a fraction
others of you will get back a decimal
okay if you've got decimal that's great
just leave it where it is
if like me you've got the fraction okay
if i want a percentage i've got to get
it out of that so that's why i press
this button here
it's just above the orange delete button
okay
of course if you've got a decimal in the
first place and you press sd you'll get
back a fraction because it flips between
the two and you can press it as many
times as you like
and you'll see what happens okay now
what we want is the decimal can someone
read to me what is the decimal that
you've got there yeah
is that right yeah seven sixes okay now
i want us to look at this carefully
because this is a really important idea
this is what the calculator tells you
this is vitally important to understand
okay uh that number there is not
five-twelfths
it's not five to us the calculator is
lying to you
except it kind of doesn't have a choice
right this is um the reason why it's
seven
sixes and not say two or three or
twenty is just because that's how much
space the calculator has on the screen
to show you
right so showing you as many numbers as
it can
you might guess right as it goes six six
six six six and so on right
the sixes go on forever they do go on
forever they're supposed to
we have a way of writing that does
anyone remember what it is yeah
that's right so let me go up here
5 12 what it's really equal to is 0.416
and then
six is forever okay so that's what that
repeated dot
yes that's a great question now why does
it end with a seven
and not with a six if these are all
supposed to be sixes
yeah morgan because with the last
decimal you look at it and
so say that's that seven used to be a
six right
but then you looked at the previous not
the previous decimal and saw that it was
five or above which it is which means
it's six
and then you add one onto the previous
six to make it seven because just
because you round it up okay because
that's how you're doing
like chinese troops no no i think i
think we're on the right track there but
maybe not everyone caught that
explanation let me see if i can reword
it tell me if i got it right
there really are sixes that go on
forever they really are okay
and so i've drawn more of them i've
drawn more than your calculator can
handle
okay but at some point you know after
well sorry where is the point one two
three
four five six seven here at this point
it's like the calculator says
sorry guys i'm out of space this number
here
that's the last number that i can put in
there i just don't have room for anymore
okay
so it has to make a decision right it
says
what's this 6 what's it closest to right
and the answer is because there's all
these
sixes over here right that means this
six is closer to a seven than a six
isn't it it's like point three three two
three close to a seven and it's point
six six six away from the six
so it makes this judgment it says i'm
gonna bump that guy up
right this is rounding okay so he rounds
it up to a seven but the important thing
to get is
it's not really a seven it's just close
to a seven it's the closest that the
calculator can get
six okay it is really meant to be a six
but it rounds off okay
so that's why when you're doing your
answers in um
like in a test or you're exercising that
kind of thing please don't write down
the seven as if that's what the
actual number is it's just that it's
close to six you can see the pattern
okay great now
there it is as a decimal okay well there
it is as a decimal
but i don't want a decimal i want a
percentage so how do i turn
the decimal into a percentage
we're pretty good last lesson we looked
at going from percentages to decimals do
you remember that
okay how did we do it like if i said if
i said 15
how do you turn that into a decimal what
did you do to it
you have to divide by something don't
you you divide by 100
and you get 0.15 okay so therefore to go
the other way
this way we have to not divide
but we have to multiply it times right
so you want to take this number
okay and you want to multiply it by
a hundred okay you do that in fact you
don't really need your calculator to do
that do you we can do that in our heads
can't we
what do we do when you multiply by a ten
or a hundred a thousand yeah
you add zeros now i don't have many
zeros here i just got this one out the
front
okay so instead i have to sort of work
with this decimal point don't i what
happens to it for one yeah you know
that's right so the same the sort of
equivalent thing to adding to zeros
is moving the decimal place twice it
should be here now
okay so therefore what's our percentage
good 41.1 now i i just made this
question up
so i didn't tell you what decimal place
i guess seven we can say that and say
that's
one decimal place
so you've got 41.7 of the donuts that's
not too bad
okay